the US government's advisory panel on
dietary guidelines is suggesting a sugar
tax as a way to cut down on sweets
what's their argument and what's the
initial reaction to the proposals well
it's been fascinating over the last hour
and a half or so since these guidelines
came out mark to see what's been going
on you immediately saw shares drop for
companies ranging from pepsi to Hershey
markets were definitely watching this
report because you saw a committee that
really took its instructions to take a
look soup to nuts of the food system in
the u.s. quite seriously they talked
about red meat being cut down they were
talking about specific sugar targets for
the first time ever and they got into
policy issues including recommending
sugar taxes now in the last hour or so
I've just been speaking with Agriculture
Secretary Tom Vilsack and you can see
things getting reeled back a bit the
government actually will put together
the final final recommendations later
this year and he says that he doesn't
want the government to be coloring
outside the lines if they get too far
field into certain questions the core
mission from the statute of looking into
actual recommendations for what you
should and shouldn't eat could get
obscured so he wants to be a little more
cautious than what the committee was
originally saying Alan what's the
reaction from meat companies red meat
doesn't do well in these guidelines but
the way we've been reading this so far
the companies may have dodged a bullet
well there was some concern from meat
lobbies that all meat was basically
going to be frowned upon in these
guidelines and what you saw instead was
really at the very beginning of them an
explicit statement that lean meat can be
part of a healthy diet but at the same
time red meats processed meats were
really looked down upon in these
guidelines and that has the industry
concerned that in the end this is an
anti meat set of recommendations they're
saying that it's contradictory since red
meats can be lean meats and you can see
this talking point emerging over the
next few months Alan what happens now
with these guidelines in the end how
much do they really matter well where
they matter is that this is something
that is the basis of federal nutrition
programs this is something that is
looked at as guidance for what is now my
plate formerly the food pyramid the icon
is created from that but at the same
time this bully pulpit from the
committee
can't be underestimated as a way to set
discourse again USDA and HHS led by HHS
the Department of Health and Human
Services will come up with their
guidance at the end of the year may well
be much narrower than what we saw today
but this doesn't get taken back this is
now part of the discussion alen on
another topic today you were at the
USDA's first forecast for crop
production this year what do they see
farmers planning this spring yes it's
been a busy as well as a cold day in
Washington the USDA released its first
forecast for prop acres this year they
saw that corn wheat and cotton Anchorage
is all going to be down that wasn't a
surprise given the low prices that we've
been seeing but we also saw a reduction
in soybean acreage which is a little bit
of a surprise since a lot of farmers are
being considering switching from corn to
soybeans